most of you are not yet at the brick
wall where you like I can't go any
further or I've got an answer but it's
clearly not right but most of you are if
you're not at the brick wall you're
heading towards it okay so I'm going to
stop you now and I'm gonna walk you
through how this works
okay so either set up maybe I should get
the question hmm I pull this car
approaches an intersection at 80 feet
per second okay so at this point by the
way if you have your police car going
down or going your right for whatever I
hope you sense now it doesn't matter
which directions it's going in so long
as everything is relative to each other
the same as mine or yours the maps will
end up being the same okay so anyway
police cars going 80 feet a second okay
crazy Imperial wizards and a car sorry
when it is 200 feet from the
intersection so this distance here a car
crosses the intersection traveling at a
right angle from the police car at the
rate of 60 feet of snow if the policeman
directs his be flight which yeah I don't
even know what that means really but
he's gonna be pointing in the car that's
Newport at the second car how fast is
the light beam turning two seconds later
a suing both cars continue with their
original race so at this point you're
like hmm what's what's going on okay
this is the the moment where it starts
and then two seconds passed right so if
this is you know your police car here
and this is your second car I'm at the
intersection right two seconds passed so
I assume the police car gets closer to
the intersection so you might be saying
Hyup right and then the other car is
still driving in the same direction was
so maybe it's moved up here okay and the
actual quantity the how fast is this
thing turning right refers to the angle
between these two points so that angle
there via
okay now so far most of you it seems to
me have said look I've got pee and I've
got C and then but their positions are
changing alright song called this X and
I know what DX of DT is DX ability is go
rate of the police car right so you'd
say DX on DT is um well some of you have
780 and I've forgotten but actually he's
getting closer to the intersection so
really should be negative right
so it'd be minus eighty and then you've
got the other guy and so we'll call this
distance say why that's almost if you
have corner and you know his rate as
well so you got dy DT being equal to now
this rate is growing so it's 60 okay and
then you think to yourself here's my set
up and now as usual I go to chain right
so I would say what I'm after this
defeat upon DT okay so that's going to
be equal to defeat up on something times
something on DT and then you pause for a
moment because you look at what you got
here and usually there's just one thing
to choose from up here and it's like an
A or a V or an X or whatever okay and
you could think ok woke up DX on 18 I've
got DUI and eat it so which would I
choose and then you might think watch
I'll just slap an X in there cfd X but
then you realize you're my problem
okay dieppe so DT that's fine but defeat
RDX defeat on DX that same is some
relationship between theta and X which
is true there is a relationship between
theta and X but theta depends on more
than just what X's doesn't have theta
this ankle comprises of these two sides
right and they're both changing that's
why this is the example I chased after
because usually it's just like one guy
you know the radar tracking station
who's stationary and the plane is flying
past okay so there's just one thing
that's changing that's why
put it in here but there's two
quantities changing so if I've got my
X's in here where the whether the Y's go
and clearly the question our solution
has to take the wires into account
because they're changing okay they
affect the answer so what do we do okay
what I'm going to suggest is you scrap
all of this okay because basically this
is what I mean by you're heading towards
a brick wall this setup is flawed
already okay because you've got this
which ignores Y which you can't do it
you can't ignore what right so we need
to rephrase this in a way which will
take Y into account okay so we mention
with me I'm going to get rid of all of
this and if you've got something similar
to this I'm going to suggest that you
also get rid of it okay so